hilly hindi h-i-l-l-y h-i-n-d-i
hannah hindi h-a-n-n-a-h
h-i-n-d-i perfect so
first and foremost in a nutshell how
would you to describe your channel to
somebody who might not be familiar with
youtube
um the hillywood show is a parody
channel
but we parody movies tv shows
celebrities of your favorite fandoms
so we've done like for movies the lord
of the rings harry potter
um for tv shows supernatural doctor who
sherlock the umbrella academy
and we've been around for quite some
time
and the thing that people don't know
about us when you see our channel
it looks huge and well produced and it's
just us it's just us we're not sponsored
we don't have a network behind us
and we do it all on our own you know you
have been creating these videos for a
long time now and
when you look back at some of your
earliest content versus now
what has been the biggest change but
also what has stayed
consistent for you guys oh the
biggest change i think the biggest
change is the camera the camera quality
that's exactly yeah that has
changed um probably the fact that as
time has gone gone on we've been more
detailed
more detailed to where we're like oh no
we're just a little too detailed but um
consistency wise
we've never broken from our tradition of
actually really truly loving a fandom
yeah we won't do a fandom unless we know
everything about it or
we ourselves truly love it that has
stayed consistent
um you'll see the biggest jump though in
costume quality
in wig quality and set design
budget-wise has been a big change for us
over the years you know we would
you know take it out of our own pocket
and um
people would donate like props and
things to the little hillywood show
because we were just local girls doing
you know
we didn't go to hollywood so we created
hillywood
um and beyond that now we are we
are a hundred percent fan funded on
patreon.com
hillywood so everything is provided by
fans
worldwide the goal of the hillywood show
is obviously to be picked up by a
network and we're still looking for that
opportunity 2020 kind of set us back
but we're very hopeful that maybe a
producer will collaborate with us and
that we can get in there and start
pitching because we just feel like the
hillywood show has grown so much
and we're ready for the next big step
now those little details people might
not think of but
they make the biggest difference and i
was looking through some of your comment
sections
and your fans notice it too they're like
wow how did you recreate this
set to look exactly like this and you
know how much time
and forethought goes into that i'm sure
quite a bit
too much time yeah too much too much
time over the years it's taken
longer and longer um and i feel like
it's because we just keep going bigger
and bigger
um we don't mean to it's more just the
fact of
hey fans would truly love to see it and
so we kind of
put ourselves in that position but um
it's taught us a lot and it's actually
made us appreciate
set designers and set dressers and all
that
detail that we literally don't really
notice until we sit down and go okay
what is in that corner what's on that
wall and you're like
oh no i mean the problem was once we
started doing it
everyone started catching on so that
became a big part of our legacy
um that you know these these two girls
can just
almost recreate this big budget for
little to no budget
and it's very difficult though it's not
easy it's not easy
for us we would love for a bigger budget
someday um i think like
umbrella academy apparently it took
about what how many weeks
like three weeks just to do objects
within the sets like searching and
finding and
yeah so that's just set dressing but
we're yeah we're very humble we still
see flaws in our work and we still want
to grow from that
um we don't think like we've
done it all we because i feel like we
can do so much more
um so that's always been our ambition is
just like let's just do it do it and
not forcing ourselves like go big or
better it has to be better than the
other one it's just
the concept the imagination keeps
growing
and we're very excited to see what god
will open
up for us in the future yeah um and i
love that
yeah hopefully it was hard it was hard
for us the pandemic was definitely hard
um
because my happiness comes from being on
set with my sister
doing what i love acting and she does
what she
loves with uh directing so last year we
had to take
a little change in gear i think everyone
was a little confused
and thankfully though our fans have been
with us
they're still on patreon they're still
supporting us
and we've done the podcast we've done a
hillywood podcast now i'm
doing twitch on the side so things have
been provided but i'm just
itching to get back into my element yeah
that actually was one of my questions
which was how has the pandemic
impacted your content and so if you want
to
elaborate even more on what you guys
have had to put to the side
what you've done instead go for it
yeah um so the pandemic hit us
hard in 2020 because at the start of
that year we were very excited
because we had very exciting meetings
planned with um
some networks and we were extremely
hopeful
we were we had that passion that fire
and then the lockdown on your mark get
set
and then the lockdown happened and
that took you know that took us back a
step i'm not going to say we were
clicking our heels throughout 2020 we
definitely weren't we had our moments
of you know disappointment and
discouragement but we really just
latched onto our faith and just
trusted that no matter what's going to
happen uh if we're meant to continue the
hillywood show god will continue to
provide
and that's what happened our fans
continued to support us throughout all
of 2020
even though we couldn't do a big
production we did nothing
production-wise last year it was
impossible
because we're we're only you know
two-girl team like we can't just say hey
we're gonna lock down everyone's gonna
quarantine above
big production like you know we're not
we're not a production house
right so for us it's much harder that's
when we branched out to
podcasts and twitch gaming and extra
content on the side
just to keep our fans happy and smiling
and they
they seem very happy but this year we're
really trying to either
get back into zoo meetings with some
important people
or um just do a little production on our
own once again
um it'll be much more difficult but
we're ready for it we're determined
yes when you're saying you know you're a
two-person team
and there's all these actors with you
guys obviously someone's running the
cameras
walk me through a bit how you know how
that process works when you decide to
create a video
hilly comes up with the entire concept
the idea uh if a song is involved
obviously umbrella academy parody took a
different turn
um that one we wanted to be a little
more creative with um
so she gives the idea and then from
there
presents everything to me from the
camera angles to
what sets we're having it's the entire
cinematography of it
and then from there i said okay now i
need to organize
and it's literally everything from you
know
scheduling is a big one scheduling
getting the crew together for
those 10 days of filming which by the
way our crew shows up
has no clue what's going on they just no
but seriously they've been this way for
years we don't have
time for like meetings it's just show up
and they go where do you want the camera
and we go
it's here it pushes in i'll tell you
when go slow
okay go and we just shoot and we just do
it and they've trusted us because most
of our crew has been there for
years they trust us and they they know
we know what we want
um and then basically me and you kind of
do costumes together costuming
we'll do our makeup makeup and we put
makeup on other makeup on others
um we do location scouting we meet with
set designers tell them exactly what we
want we usually do the set dressing
we supervise the special effects so
we'll work with people who are doing the
special effects they'll
send us um their dailies and their
examples and then we
oversee that and we can you know point
out oh well that needs a little bit more
you know blending this you know isn't
working um we work with composers who do
it we have
set designers sound mixers
um so and then and saying that and then
saying that
and saying that we then switch gears to
post production
and that's when i take over with all the
editing and the digital grading
um we we worked with the sound mixer
before that was very nice working
that was awesome we usually do all the
sound mixing uh with all the levels but
it was very nice working to sit
and engineer and have a proper engineer
so even though we do everything we are
at a point where we're ready
for something for a team for a hillywood
team
yeah hopefully funded by like a network
because
it is very trying and we're trying to
run like
a cnn channel over here it's just like
two of us now we're like so yeah we're
ready for the next step
but that's how we would in a nutshell is
basically it's just the two of us
yes we have crew show up we can't do it
without them like the days of filming
um they're there for like the ten to
fourteen days we have fun a lot we have
a great time good relationships with the
people we work with so much support
yes support and it couldn't be done with
everyone's
without everyone without volunteering
and being there for us our grandma
does part of our costumes as well our
grandmother fun back story is our
grandmother
worked for 40 years at caesar's palace
as the wardrobe department and she's
worked with frank sinatra
the beach boys celine dion i'm like
grandma
you're like she's got the connections
that's crazy
oh my gosh she still is a seamstress she
still helps us so without
our grandmother helping us like with all
of our amazing costumes she's made some
from scratch for us so she's
yeah it's a family affair so is this
your full-time job for both of you
no unfortunately not we're part-time
dance instructors
um but that kind of shifted a little bit
in the pandemic so like i said last year
wasn't easy
um but it's yeah
we we hope one day i think one day it
could be full
our full-time career because uh you know
we are so thankful for the fan donations
we are so thankful for the fans
supporting us but
sometime in their life i would like them
not to
have to give i want them just to watch
and to enjoy
because uh that's just my heart though
like i want them to not feel like
responsible for continuing the journey
yeah um i want them to sit back and
relax one day and be like wow like
look how look at their journey i
supported that uh
so we have a dream and uh we're very
hopeful we're still very hopeful that
someday something will happen that will
open it up for us
when it comes to you know money-wise
like fans donating do you guys make
money off of these videos i know some
youtube content
creators are like this is our
salary or whatever you know how does
that work for you guys
well unfortunately with youtube usually
you have to have a sponsor to be making
more money per thousand views
yes for example yes well we don't have
any sponsors we've never had
sponsors um so for example
i think it's like something like you
make a dollar per thousand
view yeah but youtube takes 40 percent
of that yeah
so there ain't nothing coming through
youtube
for us there's something there's
something that we're thankful for
there's something but it's very small
and not
as much as like what it costs for our
type of content um for other youtubers
who do like vlogs
and easier easier videos that would
probably help them
much more yeah absolutely we're just a
different breed
so that's the you know we unfortunately
can't just rely on youtube
youtube used to be more reliable with
monetization but you know once
i think it switched over with google
there was a little bit change in the
percentage
and so that's when a lot of youtubers
branched out to gofundmes and
patreon to just try to help themselves
but
like i said our story is very different
from the normal youtubers we're not the
typical
our videos are not like and um oh
no not at all we should be probably
posting much more
uh constantly maybe you know every other
week but
our fans wait around six to eight months
for one big production and they treat us
like a little
television show and i'm like thank you
bless you because
i know that's not youtube standards yeah
when it comes to
you know your relationship with these
studios
what is that like because you are using
you know their
ideas or content or music how does that
work
that oh wow it is one of the most
exciting parts
um we've been in touch with so many
um people involved with the shows
um for example when we first did lady
gaga she posted and tweeted about it
um we've worked with the cast of cw's
supernatural
um that was a huge blessing to where
they even came back for
a sequel um and they were on our sets
just you know
participating in something that we can
bring to the fans yeah that was
promotes their show um we got a call
from steve blackman
who's the showrunner of the umbrella
academy at netflix
he called us and he emailed us and he's
like i just watched like the preview
like
what the heck this is the most amazing
thing um
and it's just been such a humbling
encouraging
yeah experience and you know we would
love to just work with you
out one day to be like hey let's team up
let's do this thing
um because like i said sky's the limit
for the hillywood show
uh but working with people like that has
been one of the biggest blessings that
has been provided for us i don't know
how it happened like i don't know
why they respond or what i think it's
because we don't make
fun fun like we don't make
show and their lives work right
a joke a joke yeah we celebrate it by
adding
by a tongue-in-cheek parody where we do
kind of poke a little fun at the obvious
inside jokes but that's why we are we
are such hardcore
fans with anything we do so it would be
very hard for us to parody something
that we're not fans of i don't think he
would get that same
feel and that vibe from it uh because we
think we'd be very confused um
but we parody what we're fans of and we
want other people to be like oh my god
that is such a good parody
maybe i'll check out the actual show
that's what the hillywood show is we
just love
love those fandoms we're like let's
celebrate that
and you can tell when you're watching
the videos too it's almost like
everybody's in on the joke you're not
like you said you're not making fun of
someone
or a show or whatever it's your part of
it
and is it is it encouraging to hear back
from
the people that are involved in these
shows or the music and to
have them say hey what you guys are
doing is is really good
and i even want to be involved in it
like what is that like
um crazy overwhelming
it's it's just to where you sit back and
you get um like
chills in a way because you're like i
was not like in no way do we ever create
these going
i hope they'll see it like that's never
our goal
it's for the fans because we're like hey
we're fans of lord of the rings so we
did this production we're fans of
stranger things so we did this and we're
like
hopefully you guys loved it as much as
we were geeking out
being in costume and having this set and
it's just so much fun and we want people
to enjoy that and to bring more to that
fandom so
when you hear someone who's involved in
it uh
give you a compliment it makes our hard
work
it just makes it so worth hanging out
yeah because nothing has ever been easy
on the hollywood show it's always you
run into difficult problems here and
there with filming it's
never been easy um it's just it's so
humbling and so encouraging very
encouraging it gives us hope for the
future
yes when it comes to you know las vegas
specifically what is the youtube
uh community like here
i i don't know if i know many i think
um i think there was a creator i don't
remember his screen name but i think
there was a creator back in the day
um that i knew he lived here but we
never
spoke because his channel was like so
much bigger than ours so i was too
embarrassed like ever asked
that was when we first started out um
but i don't know too many in las vegas
and like i said most of everybody who
meets that's like oh you're from l.a
because you're productions you're you're
in you're in l.a you're working in l.a
you know come on you're hollywood it's
like no
i'm a vegas girl and we love working
here because there are so
many talented people like the set
designers that we work with
are vegas like locals as well and they
are beyond
amazing um same with even like our
camera operator
um our the our crew like everyone that
we've
chosen to be a part of the hillywood
show when we're on set
working works in vegas vegas locals yeah
we're very talented bunch
and alicia get more of us
so when it like it's interesting to hear
like
the youtube community isn't i wouldn't
say strong but maybe there's not a lot
of networking in there
do you think there's enough like there
should be more opportunities
for that i think so
i think there's there should be more of
a freeway
uh between youtubers um i know sometimes
in the past so we've tried to connect
with some
other youtubers and it's almost harder
to connect with a youtuber
than an actor because we've worked with
actors before
and i don't like it's kind of hard to
explain like the concepts and things
um to each other so there's just a
little bit less communication i think
between the two parties but once you
make a friend with a youtuber
they're like forever your friend and
because they get it
they can relate uh so we've met some
great people along the journey but they
we are kind of hard to get a hold of
yeah it is true
i don't know why what are some of the
benefits of
creating content in las vegas versus
say los angeles or san francisco or you
know
what have you i would have to say
honestly budget but
i'll just about to say yeah
budget wise uh you know every
everybody's
dying to get into those studios in la so
they're just filled up so
back to back because that's what the
industry is there
so they raise the prices because it's on
high demand and here in vegas
yes sometimes you get backed up and we
have to wait a month to get in there or
something
but really it's just reasonable prices
uh very decent
people and oh my god let's just talk
about how much more space there is
with parking moving vehicles driving to
the location
driving and park traffic we have parking
here we don't
you don't have to wake up two hours
ahead of time to get to the vegas set
here yes so i guess those are like some
of our that's
the biggest biggest things is oh we're
done filming okay let's all go back to
our
you know residential places that we
sleep
and um it doesn't take you an hour to
two hours to get home it's like you know
however far away you know because vegas
from one end to the other is what
45 minutes it might be more of maybe
like an incentive to do it like you know
i don't have to wake up
two hours early like it's just a much
easier process
yeah it's more reasonable yeah
definitely especially if you're
balancing
other work too which you guys are and
i'm sure the people you work with are
as well yeah it's true from what i heard
that's very interesting is that
a lot of la productions are
coming over here to film because of such
strict um protocols with covid right now
that are going over there so a lot of
them have
switched gears and are actually using
some of our vegas stages
um and i it's kind of sad vegas has lost
a lot of sound stages
um because we kind of had like a dead
season like oh not too many people are
coming to vegas anymore they're going to
georgia they're going to canada
they're going to you know los angeles
and we kind of were like oh we lost that
so a lot of the film studios we worked
at no
longer like the sound stages don't exist
um so we've done some scrambling but now
all of a sudden
people have their eyes back on vegas and
they're like hey you guys
we're like come over here but you know
there's not as many sound stages so we
got to make room for everybody
uh so i thought that was very
interesting made me excited again so i
love that that is very interesting and i
you know maybe it'll it'll help more
people in the city to get work and that
sort of thing
because it's been a hard year yes
absolutely i hope so i'm excited about
it
come back come back to vegas what's next
for you guys i know we talked a bit
about the you know working with the
studio i'd love to hear more about that
and then also
is there an idea or a show or a song
that you guys
love to parody but you just haven't done
it yet
oh two-part question um okay we'll start
with the the
latter part one of the productions we
would love to do
is something based on star wars we grew
up with that
fandom um as well and we just absolutely
adore it but
it is such a big undertaking and
budget wise we're not quite sure if we
could meet the standards
because we don't ever want to parody
something and
everyone expects it to be a certain way
and we couldn't reach their expectations
we want to feel confident
and we want to feel strong about it and
go big or go home
so that one's always been shelf i'm like
not yet
one day yeah one day with regards to our
future
um we are very hopeful um
that we will be able to have that
opportunity to
meet with a network or producers and
start getting in there and start
pitching what we do best
um we have a huge um
ambition a huge passion for filmmaking
and acting
and we really feel like we can create
even more magic and something even more
spectacular than what we bring to
youtube
yeah that would be amazing it's like you
see the magic on youtube just imagine it
on a bigger platform
ah so yeah we're very hopeful and we
just we're praying for that opportunity
and hopefully you know someday somebody
will look at us and be like yep let's
let's start working on that let's see
what we can like we're gonna keep
knocking this year and keep trying we're
not gonna give up
never give up yeah and and we're we're
talking through
you know also on top of that another
production idea hopefully for this year
you know but whatever comes our way
we're gonna yes take it
take it by the reins and hold on yes
is there anything else that you want to
add that i didn't ask about that you
think is is important to
talk about well i think the biggest
thing that
we always like to mention is the fact
that we couldn't do any of this
without our fans um we would have had to
close our doors a long
time ago without their love and support
um
and i just want them to know that we we
wouldn't be where we're
at without their viewership without
their
shares and likes and comments all that
matters to youtubers more than you know
your love that little comment that says
this video makes me smile
or you just even leave a little emoji
with hearts those things
is what fuels our creativity to
help push us to never give up because it
is hard
when you're self you know we're
basically
our own little brand yeah it's hard to
kind of get that motivation so without
them we wouldn't be existing right now
and on top of that those who have taken
that further step
to donate or give whatever they can
on our patreon is extremely uh
encouraging and um just so
uplifting um because we did pray in 2020
that
you know give us a sign if we're meant
to keep going you know we were very
close to shutting the doors
and we kept praying and people kept
coming through and we tell them you are
our angels you are the answer
there are miracles so thank you
tell our fans thank you